la nuit
[Musique]
fait la cour
fab n en sera la tête d'affiché ce jeune
rambolitains a accepté de jouer au
deuxième concert guitare et solidarité
une après-midi organisé par le lion's
club de rambouillet on va s'amuser en
même temps on peut aider donc pas
d'hésitation j'écoute beaucoup de
musique anglo saxonne comme justement la
folk irlandaise comme damian rice ou des
choses beaucoup plus populaires comme
jason mraz
j'aime bien les sonorités et puis écrire
en français sur ce type de musique est
évidemment souchon c'est un exemple au
moins en terme d'écriture
m
tu es
le 29 octobre quatre heures de concert
joue aussi caroline bio marie platel les
élèves de l'école de musique d'elancourt
ou encore le duo cadet clem autour d'un
seul instrument la guitare
les guitares c'est un instrument
international populaire facile à
transporter qui a été sur tous les
continents l'afrique l'europe l'amérique
du sud l'asie on joue de la guitare par
tous c'est un langage international
l'objectif est double c'est de permettre
à des d'une part permettre à des jeunes
talents de s'exprimer mais aussi à des
des retraités qui joue très bien qu'ils
cherchent des chaînes des scènes et
aussi de surtout collecter des fonds les
fonds iront à des actions sociales et
humanitaires
l'an dernier le lay en ce club avait
récolté près de 3000 euros